we have an important preface an
important caveat
an important disclaimer before we get
started and here it is
provided from my lovely lawyers here we
go
i am not an investment advisor all
opinions are mine alone there are risks
involved in placing any investment in
securities or in bitcoin or in
cryptocurrencies or in anything
none of the information presented today
or really anytime since you might be
listening to this anytime is intended to
form the basis for any offer or
recommendation or have any regard to the
investment objectives financial
situation
or needs of any specific person that
includes you my dear listener
so everything you're going to hear is
for informational entertainment
purposes only and with that said please
enjoy
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the tim ferriss show
where it is normally my job to interview
world-class performers
to tease out the habits routines etc
that you can apply
to your own lives this episode is a
special episode
and it is a very
detailed action-packed episode at least
it was for me
and in a sense it pairs really well with
an earlier episode
in 2017 i did an episode with nival
ravikant
who joins me again in this round two
with
nick zabo and the title of that episode
was
the quiet master of cryptocurrency and
it really covered
everything related to bitcoin so btc
smart contracts all of those
fundamentals this volume
2 is going to cover everything ethereum
and the two people joining me i already
named one are
naval ravicant uh as i might have
mentioned and he is really
the pilot for this conversation so he
takes the reigns
as the interviewer you can find him on
twitter at naval n-a-v-a-l
he is the co-founder and chairman of
angellist he is an angel investor and
has invested in more than 100 companies
including
many huge successes including twitter
uber
notion open door postmates and wish
among many
many many many others you can subscribe
to naval his podcast on wealth and
happiness on
apple podcast spotify overcast wherever
you get your podcast
you can also find his blog at naval
that's nav.a-l
the guest of honor and the
real expert in this particular episode
is vitalik buterin
on twitter at vitalik buterin
v-i-t-a-l-i-k
b-u-t-e-r-i-n vitalik is the creator of
ethereum
he first discovered blockchain and
cryptocurrency technologies through
bitcoin in 2011
and was immediately excited by the
technology and its potential
he co-founded bitcoin magazine in
september 2011 and after two and a half
years
looking at what the existing blockchain
technology and applications had to offer
wrote the ethereum white paper in
november 2013 it is hard to believe that
it was so
relatively recent he now leads
ethereum's research team working on
future versions of the ethereum protocol
in 2014 vitalik was
a recipient of the two-year teal
fellowship tech billionaire peter
thiel's project that awards 100 000
to 20 promising innovators under 20 so
they can pursue
their inventions in lieu of a
post-secondary institution
and boy oh boy did that award turn into
a hell of a lot of value
for the world and a lot of people
and vitalik i believe is now a ripe old
27 years old you can find his writing
and much more
at vitalik.ca that's v i t
a l i k dot c a
and for ease of reference and ease of
finding you can find the previous
conversation
with nick zabo on bitcoin and smart
contracts and
other core concepts at tim dot blog
forward slash bitcoin and you can also
find
this current conversation with vitalik
on all things ethereum
at tim dot blog forward slash ethereum
that's e-t-h-e-r-e-u-m
please enjoy this wide-ranging
conversation
with vitalik buterin and naval robicont
this episode is brought to you by
theragun i have
two theraguns and they are worth their
weight in gold i've been using them
every single day whether you're an elite
athlete or just a regular person trying
to get through your day
muscle pain and muscle tension are real
things
that's why i use the theragun i use it
at night i use it
after workouts it is a handheld
percussive therapy device that releases
your deepest
muscle tension so for instance at night
i might use it on the bottom of my
feet it's helped with my plantar
fasciitis i will
have my girlfriend use it up and down
the middle of my back and i'll use it on
her it's an easy way for us to actually
trade massages in effect and you can
think of it in fact
as massage reinvented on some level
helps with performance
helps with recovery helps with just
getting your back
to feel better before bed after you've
been sitting for way too many hours
i love this thing and the all-new gen 4
theragun
has a proprietary brushless motor that
is surprisingly quiet it's easy to use
and about as quiet as an electric
toothbrush it's pretty astonishing
you really have to feel the theragun's
signature power amplitude and
effectiveness to believe it
it's one of my favorite gadgets in my
house at this point so
i encourage you to check it out try
theragun that's thera t-h-e-r-a-g-u-n
there's no substitute for the gen 4
theragon
with an oled screen that's oled for
those wondering that's
organic light emitting diode screen
personalized theragon app an
incredible combination of quiet and
power so go to theragun.com
tim right now and get your gen 4th era
gun today
or you can watch the videos on the site
which show you all sorts of different
ways to use it
a lot of runner friends of mine use them
on their it bands after long runs
there are a million ways to use it and
the gen fourth era guns start at
just 199 dollars i said i have two i
have the prime
and i also have the pro which is like
the super cadillac version my girlfriend
loves these soft attachments
on that so check it out go to
theragon.com
tim one more time theragun.com
tim
this episode is brought to you by peak
pique
in their brand new supplement daily
immune vitamin c optimized for
absorption americans are arguably famous
for having the world's most expensive
urine so are you absorbing your vitamin
c
or just peeing it out studies have shown
that you might absorb less than 50
percent
of vitamin c when you consume amounts
over 1000 milligrams also
a gram those are the same thing peaks
daily immune is maximized for absorption
with liposomal encapsulation technology
liposomes help deliver vitamin c to
exactly where you need it your cells
not just your bladder and i've been
using their packets
now for a few weeks i've gone through a
number of boxes
and i typically take one to two per day
as i would say maintenance kind of
support dose and i'll take
more than that if i feel any type of
cold coming on or any symptoms there of
peaks unique formula supports a healthy
immune
system and daily immune features a
buffered non-acid
form of vitamin c that's gentle on your
stomach it is a powerful and
absorbable vitamin c that fits in your
pocket and tastes great so i will often
take a handful of these just stick them
in a jeans pocket for
the day and then every few hours open up
a packet plus it contains just seven
clean ingredients no preservatives
refined sugar or additives all you need
to do is open and squeeze it into your
mouth
no glass water or spoon needed
personally i like to have a small
chaser of water or carbonated water but
you don't need it you can do it on the
run
it's so easy and tastes so good think
black european elderberries
that is the flavor i've been consuming
you might choose to take it once or
twice a day or more
as i do there's a reason peaks products
have more than fifteen thousand five
star
reviews people are very happy with their
products try it for yourself risk free
with their 30 day satisfaction guarantee
you either love it or you get your money
back so go to
t dot com slash tim that's p i q u e
t e a dot com slash tim and use code tim
tim check out to get five percent off of
your first order
plus free shipping when you purchase a
bundle that's
peak t one more time p i q u e t
e a dot com slash tim and use code tim
for five percent off plus free
u.s shipping on a bundle
at this altitude i can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start to
shake
can i answer your personal questions
[Music]
i'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal endoskeletons
tim this is naval speaking tim thanks
for having us we're joined by vitalik
buterin
vitalik is the i believe now 27 year old
creator of ethereum which is the most
exciting
cryptocurrency since bitcoin and has
incredibly broad ambitions and
capabilities
and vitalik is a really interesting guy
because not only did he create
ethereum or co-create it he also is a
multi-disciplinary polymath
his blog at vitalik.ca is full of lots
of great ideas and insights and thoughts
he runs the ethereum foundation he's
sort of contributed to
all kinds of things like automatic
market makers roll-ups social recovery
wallets decentralized finance
scalability of blockchains governance
all kinds of great ideas in the
cryptocurrency space
he also thinks a lot about public goods
radical markets
wealth distribution he runs a very
active twitter account where he good
naturally engages with all kinds of
people who are constantly trying to
get into fights with him which is kind
of what people do on twitter
and yeah and we're very lucky to have
him i would say that
for me along with nick sabo and who we
interviewed here in 2017
uh who created bit gold and coined the
term smart contracts
and along with zuko who is the
irrepressible founder of zcash i've
always found vitalik
nick and and zuko to be sort of the the
three people
on twitter that i early on learn a lot
about crypto from
so welcome vitalik and thanks for taking
the time to talk to us about yourself
and ethereum
well thank you very much for the
introduction of it's good to be here
yeah so i'm gonna start just right off
the bat we're probably
gonna try and keep this fairly basic and
high level for those of you who are
quite experienced with cryptocurrencies
this may be
a very general conversation but at the
same time i'm going to ask vitalik some
hard questions we're not going to let
him get away with
it's just the pr angle and
so but we'll start with some basics we
let's assume we know what
cryptocurrencies are and for those of
you who are not that familiar with it i
would suggest you go back to the podcast
that tim and i did with
nick sabo back in 2017 i believe that's
titled the quiet
master of cryptocurrency correct uh
so once you're kind of up to speed on
that this one will make a lot more sense
but we're going to get right into
not what is crypto or what is bitcoin
we're going to get into what is ethereum
so how do you describe it today vitalik
uh sure
so the one sentence explanation of
ethereum that i sometimes give
is it's a general purpose blockchain so
this of course makes more sense if you
kind of already know what a blockchain
is right it's
this kind of decentralized network of
many different computers that are
together like maintaining this kind of
like a ledger or this kind of database
together
different participants have like very
particular ways of plugging into that
and they can send transactions that do
very particular things
but no one can tamper with the system in
a way that's outside
of the rules and ethereum expands on the
bitcoin approach of basically saying
well instead of having
rules that are designed around
supporting one application
we're going to make something more
general purpose where people can
just build their own applications and
the rules for
whatever applications they build can be
kind of executed and
implemented on the ethereum platform so
one
explanation that i heard one person gave
us that
like bitcoin is like a yes spreadsheet
where everyone only controls their own
five squares of the spreadsheet but
ethereum is a spreadsheet with
macros right so you know everyone kind
of controls
you know their own accounts which is
kind of their own little piece of this
universe
but then these pieces of the universe
can have code and they can like interact
with each other according to
pre-programmed rules and you can build a
lot of things on top of that right like
bitcoin builds a monetary system on top
kind of famously ethereum can build you
know decentralized domain name systems
again various decentralized financial
contractions some you know prediction
markets
you know non-functional tokens and all
sorts of different
schemes that people have been coming up
with and the limit for
what you build is basically your own
creativity but like the core difference
between
building an application on ethereum
versus building it on
you know some traditional centralized
platform
is this core idea that once you build
your application
in the application does not needs to
depend on you
or any other single person for its
continued existence
and the application is guaranteed to
continue running according to the rules
that were specified
and like you do not have any ability to
kind of irregularly go in and tamper
with it
that's a great overview and i like that
excel analogy of it's a spreadsheet with
macros instead of just a spreadsheet
where you control your own cells
i'll also try and articulate in a few
ways that i understand it kind of around
the edges because i think ethereum is
one of those things that's now
quite a bit bigger than you and it
probably has evolved in ways that even
you didn't fully anticipate
so in some sense we're discovering
ethereum and no longer just building it
i also like to think of it as kind of an
unstoppable
application platform so a platform for
building unstoppable applications
kind of like a world computer where
let's say that we want to run
very very important computer programs
where we don't trust
the computer itself and we don't trust
the other people to execute code in our
behalf then we create a single world
computer
where we check the code on the machines
of many many different people all around
the world
who are properly incentivized to
maintain a single
computing state so if bitcoin is a
shared ledger then ethereum is a shared
computer for the entire world
to run its most important applications
so some of the applications that people
are building
on it are among the possibly the most
important applications
of the future so let's talk a little bit
about those applications about what this
trustless world computer is doing
what are the applications today that are
the most common and that you're most
excited about
so first of all i mean i think uh if the
asset
is a cryptocurrency and it itself is an
application and of the first application
of
ethereum going beyond financial things a
bit i mentioned
ens the ethereum name system so yeah
that's
you can think of it as a decentralized
name system
right so like for example you know when
you go to ethereum.org
there's dns domain name system which is
this big that kind of table
that maintains this mapping of well you
know if
a person enters ethereum.com the server
they actually have to talk to
to talk to the website is you know like
some particular id address
and this dns system that maintains this
kind of public relationship
is a fairly centralized system with a
very small number of servers
running it so ens is a fully
decentralized alternative that is
running on the ethereum blockchain and
you can use it not just for websites
right like you can use it just for
accounts
so for example like there is a messaging
service called status
it's like you know in terms of like what
it feels like to hear that you know it's
a messenger
it's similar to telegram we're signal or
whatsapp or any of those
um but the difference is that it is
decentralized
so there is no dependence on any single
server or like there's no dependence on
status to company
which is nice because it makes the whole
thing much more censorship resistance
it makes the whole thing just a much
more guaranteed to survive
you know regardless of what forces wish
for for its existence or wish against
its
existence in the future ens is this
really important part of it because well
if you have a chat application i need to
have some name by which i can refer to
you know the users that i want to talk
to right like i want to type in and say
i want to talk to nevada and things like
telegram and signal and whatsapp
that mapping is generally basically
kind of authenticated and controlled by
a server but whereas
in the status it's all just done by the
ethereum blockchain right so
that is one good example i think of a a
kind of
not financial but still very important
um ethereum application
now going beyond those two cases there's
a lot of
kind of more complicated things um so
there's the d5
decentralized finance space which is
this
big category that has all sorts of
interesting contraptions in it
um like so for example there's some
prediction markets
so fly forbes where you can go and like
bet on different outcomes like you know
who's going to win some sports game or
you know who's going to win some
particular election
there have been very successful
prediction markets running on the
ethereum blockchain
there's uh just markets for
trading between different kinds of
assets there's what's called
synthetic assets um so if you want to
have access to
like some mainstream real world asset
like you know what's older could be one
example but you know
you don't have to like dollars like
there's uh lots of other examples as
well
there's versions of this that are kind
of purely virtual
sort of simulated versions that exist um
purely you know within the ethereum
environment
now there's this entire kind of very
powerful financial toolkit that exists
within the ethereum ecosystem on the
whole like there's just
a lot of these uh interesting things
that happen i mean there's even games
that are based on
um ethereum there's a whole bunch of
different things
yeah in fact at d5 decentralized finance
is this gigantic new category in which
entire companies and protocols are being
built in a decentralized way
that allow you to do a lot of things
that would have required wall street
along with bankers and judges and
lawyers and accountants to handle
but now is done through smart contracts
that are living in the blockchain
on the ethereum blockchain and these
smart contracts are kind of at the core
of the ethereum blockchain we talked
about these in the next sabo podcast but
he
famously described it as like an
automated vending machine as an example
of a smart contract
where you you put in money in a certain
slot and there's a certain set of rules
and you press certain buttons and
you get certain products in exchange but
these smart contracts obviously now are
getting far far more complicated can
actually be used
not just to compose financial
applications but even applications that
we don't normally think of as
financial one way to think about it for
those of you who are into computer
programming is imagine if every piece of
a program every function
had an address from which anyone in the
world could reach it a unique identifier
address
and it had a slot into which you could
insert money so you could call any
function wherever it is in the world you
could insert money into it and it would
do something on your behalf
and so that gives ethereum applications
this very interesting property called
composability
where you can use them almost like lego
blocks each one builds on the rest
and so the final product in d5 ends up
very very advanced
in the traditional world when let's say
like robin hood builds their application
and then schwab builds another
application wisdom tree builds a mutual
fund
or an etf those can't combine with each
other but in the ethereum world of defy
all of these apps by default are open
source
permissionless programmable and can
connect right into each other they can
be identified
called and paid for in a permissionless
trustless kind of way
so the the infrastructure that gets
built in defy
and ethereum although it's it's very
difficult to build and it's complex
once a piece is built it is available to
everybody and sort of stacks on to each
other
almost to create one of those japanese
style voltron robots that just gains in
power
yeah naval let me jump in here
just as a proxy i'm not even a proxy i
am a listener
literally in this case and i'm happy to
be
the listener so i'm both a proxy and an
actual listener but
how does one think about intellectual
property if all of these
otherwise separate or previously
separate applications and so on are now
lego pieces that are kind of natively
interconnected
is that a silly question i'm just
wondering if no no it's a really good
question i mean my high level view on it
is that what blockchains do is through
consensus they protect the data
so the users own their own private data
and then sort of the public data that's
needed to make the blockchain work its
integrity is protected by the blockchain
and that's what blockchains do
they get a whole bunch of people to
cooperate on what the canonical
output should be but the code itself is
completely open it is kind of backwards
to what we're used to we're used to
closed source companies capturing value
but here all the values created by open
source but yeah
vitalik i'm sure has a different view on
this but you know there's there's lots
of copycats and clones and there's
attacks and forks and so on
and it's kind of a wild west out there
but generally
uh so far it does seem like the original
products and the best products
are succeeding the best and they're sort
of always in the scoreboard of market
cap and transactions and usage
but uh yeah it's it's a wild west out
there yeah
and i think um the blockchain
environment is
definitely a one that operates under
somewhat different rules than
the traditional environments right like
just one example of this
is like the idea of forking right uh so
one story that happened around the
beginning of last year that i just love
to tell because of how it kind of
combines together the values of the
space so nicely as
uh there was this platform called steam
and
in the steam uh there's steam the
platform and then there's steam the
company right
and like steam was its own blockchain
and steamed the company
like they did have some steam tokens um
but like they didn't have the right
to like just do whatever they want with
this theme the platform because it was a
decentralized thing
but you know they had some tokens and
then steam the platform had a voting
mechanism
and holders of esteemed tokens could
vote on changes
but then the steam the company got
bought out by justin sun
you know the infamous tron person and uh
justin's son like basically nick started
doing some things to kind of increase
his control over the
uh steam platform the community was kind
of very unhappy with him and then he
even like kind of took advantage of you
know some of the
voting mechanisms and some coins held in
exchanges to sort of seize control of uh
at least the formal rules of the
platform even further but then what
happened was that the users were built
right what the users um
said is well we're creating a new
platform called hive
and hive is just a fork of steam it is
gonna have
a start with the same or mostly the same
rules as steam
and we're even going to copy over most
of the balances
of the steam tokens except if you
participated in the attack then
you know your balance goes to zero when
you fork and
most of the users like basically that
have collectively
moved over to this new fork and you know
justin's son had this full control of an
empire but then
uh you know nobody cared about that
empire anymore because everyone now
cared about hive right
so like forking is this primitive that
exists and because of it you know you do
have this
ability for just communities to
you know exert kind of collective agency
and um
like basically protect themselves from
kind of being exploited um but at the
same time
if you as a here project team are good
to your community then
like those same effects work in your
favor right uh so
those effects work in your favor because
community is willing to support your
project
if someone makes a copycat then you know
generally very few people are willing to
kind of support and provide any
assistance to that copycat project
unless of course you do something to
betray the community's trust
in which case you know that like those
kinds of situations and the situations
that the copycat is for
i think legitimate developers have
plenty of
ability to build projects to gain
from those projects becoming successful
and there's a lot of ways in which the
crypto space does end up kind of
assuring that but you know
at the same time it's also not in
environments where anyone's level of
control was infinite and
in some ways that's the other beautiful
thing about the space
vitalik had this great line in his blog
where he said we wanted digital nations
but we got digital nationalism
um and there's a lot of truth in that
but basically these are these are like
digital nations and one of the analogies
that i use for defy
is that these are like crypto castles
made of bath
that are freely trading with each other
just imagine like people are building
applications on top of
ethereum they're protected by
mathematics those are the walls in those
castles and there are moats which are
rivers of cryptography
but then they have free trade policy
with each other so that creates a lot of
innovation
but if one of them starts misbehaving
then it's people can leave and go to the
next crypto castle or
this is where the analogy breaks down
they can actually replicate it just
create a copy and move to that one
like in the steam and hive example well
that also is
i mean it has comparables outside of the
world of
blockchain and cryptography in so much
as if we look at say wordpress as an
open
source project you have companies like
automatic
and matt mullenweg you might people may
notice that m-a-t-t in the middle of
automatic
yes which layers then these for-profit
services on top of an open source
platform and technically
someone could create a competitor but
like you said there are these
questions of viability
value-add and moral leadership and so on
right
so so there are sort of certain elements
that contribute to the ethereum
ecosystem so to speak that you can
perhaps compare to other things to help
educate people as well i was just
sort of connecting some of the stuff
that's a good analogy with with uh
wordpress
the the place where the analogies
diverge is that wordpress
it's kind of a single-player game like
each person owns their own blog
right in the ethereum world you could
use ethereum to build a twitter
that everybody owns and it requires
social consensus to operate but multiple
people can put their data
in so it's this really weird thing where
it's decentralized it's open source but
it's still used to coordinate and bring
people together
blockchains combine this really weird
combo of
individualism and individual control and
the ability to leave
along with consensus and community and
cooperation and build this giant public
good
so it is its own thing it's hard to
figure out but it's worth figuring out
because this is the next phase of the
internet after mobile
yeah let me if i could jump in just to
kind of be the kid in the corner of the
class
in the back of the class asking
questions i would love to hear from you
vitalik
what was the initial
vision for ethereum and what has most
surprised you if anything you know i was
doing a bit of reading
just on the the genesis story and
first of all i i mean maybe separately
maybe for another conversation
it seems like a lot was done right in
the beginning and i was reading a quote
from a wired piece in 2016
and it's and this please feel free to
fact check if it's not accurate but it
says you know when i came up with
ethereum my first thought was
okay this thing is too good to be true
and i'm going to have five professional
cryptographers raining down on me and
telling me how stupid i am for not
seeing a bunch of very obvious flaws
but you know dot dot two weeks later i
was extremely surprised that none of
this happened as it turned out the core
ethereum idea was good fundamentally
completely sound
i'd love to hear what the core idea was
maybe we've already stated it and it's
redundant but the initial vision
and if anything has been really
surprising to you
that has transpired since those early
days so i think the core idea
is um you know to make a general purpose
blockchain um and
to kind of open the gates for people to
build what they want to build on top of
it right like
the background kind of story for when
ethereum was starting to be formed was
that this was just the time when
the idea of a blockchain kind of beyond
bitcoin
was just starting to gain legitimacy and
people were just starting to realize
that you know there
are these applications for blockchains
other than just them
running a currency i mean it would be
nice to ability platform that can
actually support them
and so at the beginning right you had
single purpose blockchains you had
bitcoin
uh for currency you had namecoin for
domain names
you would have like single purpose
protocols like covered coins for issuing
assets
the second step is what i call the swiss
army knife protocols
so a swiss army knife protocol basically
says well here's a list of you know 25
different applications that we've
identified as being important and let's
be able to watch it to support all of
them
uh so like mastercoin was one example of
what i call the swiss army knife
protocol and the problem with the swiss
army knife protocols is that two weeks
later you know some 14 year old teenager
in finland comes up with a 26
application you have to go hard for the
protocol
so the next the natural step is this
kind of general purpose approach where
instead of your blockchain
supporting 25 applications your
blockchain supports a programming
language and
whatever a system with whatever rules he
wants to build
you write that in a piece of code and
the nodes in the network
can all execute the code and the network
kind of helps to
collaboratively enforce the rules of
this code for
the um objects that are in your
particular application
so that was kind of the technical uh
perspective and then there was also the
perspective of well you know what did i
envision people building on top of it
it's actually surprising how it hasn't
changed that much
i'm like i remember some of the very
earliest applications
included kind of financial gadgets so
contracts for difference were one
example
which is uh you know one very particular
subset of the thing that today we call
d5
decentralized file storage uh like you
know paid people to store a gigabyte of
your data
um was one thing i was excited about um
decentralized name systems
was um excited about those you know
decentralized training between different
assets like
a lot of the examples of just things
that people
wanted to do with blockchains at the
time like they just
are the same as what people are doing
today though there are also new
applications right so like non-fungible
tokens um
that i briefly mentioned nfts the idea
here is basically
just create a yet token that you know
represents something other than
a financial asset and one example of
this could be that an nft can represent
video game assets
and nft could represent like a digital
work of art
where he wants to sell kind of like
basically breaking rights as being the
original owner of it
and you know there's a lot of these
different use cases and these uh right
now the nftm ecosystem has been
extremely successful
um about a week ago there was a yeah a
neon cat nft that got sold for the
equivalent of about 580 000 dollars
and so that's an example of a new thing
another example of an old thing
is that daos decentralized autonomous
organizations
and so the idea here is well you know
let's build an
organization where the rules for the
decision making in that organization
you know the equivalent of like
shareholder or board voting or whatever
he wants to use
could just be written as rules in a
smart contract and then
the program that executes those rules
can be directly in control of
whatever assets the organization is
supposed to control
and you know we've seen a couple of
examples of
kind of simple daos in action and
make or dial which kind of maintains um
you know die
the stable coin that you know
algorithmically targets a price of one
dollar
is uh one example i mean now there's
also rye
uh you know there's a lot of examples of
this a lot of things that we expected
from the beginning um prediction markets
um also have been
part of you know what we were excited
about using blockchains for since 2014
and they're still around today so a lot
of old things and also some new things
as well
thank you extremely helpful yeah i mean
yeah some of the ones that vitalik just
laid out like
i think your recent guest katie han
mentioned nfts as nifties is what she
called it
uh no i did because i wanted to try to
oh you didn't sorry i wanted to try to
force that into the lexicon
but you got it okay well you watched
this stuff yeah
nifties yeah so nifty nifties are this
crazy idea that like owning
a digital copy of something and having
your name stamped to it somehow gives it
more value but it seems to work it works
with collectible trading cards it seems
to work with
digital art and then because of the
composability of the
ethereum infrastructure you can reuse
these
nifty items across different games
different museums different virtual
worlds
and so you own it in one place and you
own it everywhere which is a very
powerful concept
so digital scarcity was born with
bitcoin but now
extending into things that are not
fungible that are not exchangeable with
each other and that that's been frankly
for me a surprising
uh thing that is immersion ethereum you
know ethereum it's it's funny because
you're asking vitalik like what did he
expect and what do you not expect i
remember when ethereum first launched
that a lot of computer scientists i
spoke with privately said it would never
work
because it's kind of this crazy idea
that the way we're going to get a
trusted computer in the cloud is we will
each run a copy of all the computations
on all of our computers and then we'll
sync it up and make sure it matches
so that's the recipe for building the
slowest computer in the world
and but somehow we've we've gotten away
with it and so
i think the big debate now about
ethereum has shifted from
will it work to will its scale and when
i talk to my friends in the crypto
community and say hey what do you want
me to ask vitalik they send me a list
you know of many many questions but the
center
piece is always the same and like how
the heck is this thing going to scale
and i would like to get in that
conversation that is a more complicated
conversation it's technically
sophisticated
but basically we're saying hey we're
going to have one giant mainframe
computer in the cloud running everyone's
applications
so that we can all trust the computer
instead of trusting each other
but how is that going to scale isn't
that going to be the slowest computer of
all time
and so now we're in a situation where
ethereum uh
it's actually cleverly named it runs on
so-called gas quote unquote
and there's a limited amount of gas per
block in the ethereum blockchain
and frankly uh the gas the price of gas
has gone up
these decentralized finance applications
they can be very lucrative they're
trading large amounts of money
and people are eager to use them but the
price of each of these transactions is
going up
i was trying to do a small d5
transaction the other day and it was a
hundred dollar transaction and the price
was
five dollars just to execute the
transaction and that's a very very high
transaction fee and i know vitalik and
crew been working for years
on the ethereum two project to bring
that cost down
by the way as an aside that is one place
where ethereum really differs from
bitcoin bitcoin is saying we're digital
gold this thing is immutable don't
change it
and the fights in the past have been
about changing bitcoin or not there's a
big famous schism over that
but now with ethereum you know the
question is the philosophy is we do
change it we do improve it we do make it
better
but in the process there is a greater
chance that things can go wrong that it
can break
so now we're entering ethereum two which
is the scalable version of ethereum
so vitalik do you wanna give us a quick
overview of ethereum two
at a very high level and then we can
kind of dig into the pieces
i'm sure um so i think one other thing
that's important to
kind of add just to you know give a
complete picture of scaling is that
there's these two families of scaling
layer one scaling and layer two scaling
where layer one scaling basically says
well let's make the blockchain itself
better
and layer two scaling says well let's
come up with
protocols that are gonna sit on top of
the blockchain and that use the
blockchain
in more clever ways to provide the same
kinds of security guarantees that a
blockchain has um
but that provide much more scalability
because you're not just kind of doubly
staking
like literally everything and doing
everything on the blockchain directly
and so like bitcoin for example uh you
know especially after the scaling war
is like focused very exclusively on
layer two right whereas you know
say bitcoin cash is very layer one
focused and this is a this is a classic
thing in computing like so for example
when i go to a website the domain name
system
is at a different layer right the dns
servers and then the http server as a
server of the web page or another layer
on top
and there's a caching layer where some
of the data might be kept closer to me
and then on my own computers where i run
the javascript because i don't want to
run that javascript
way back on the http server or the dns
server
so there is a long rich history in
computing of stacking layers upon layers
as you get closer to the point of the
user
that's the point at which you use more
compute and you execute more and more of
the code
so basically the idea here is
decentralize only what you need to
decentralize
and so ethereum is going to split into
or it's going to have multiple layers
and i think what you're saying is layer
one is really ethereum
and that's the least scalable part but
that's where the security comes in
and layer two is where the code is run
and that's a that
that has different properties which
you're gonna get into right well
the way that i would describe it is like
in comparison to you know bitcoin which
is very early too focused on bitcoin
cash which is very earlier one focused
ethereum takes a moderate approach so we
do both kinds of scaling
right so there is the eth2 um effort
which you mentioned
um which uh you know it is later on
scaling right it is basically saying
well we're going to
make this big upgrade of the ethereum
blockchain we're going to
move it from a proof of work uh to a
proof of stake
uh where you know proof of work is this
current consensus mechanism that keeps
the blockchain secure
that runs on having a large number of
computers just constantly cranking out
these kind of mathematical hash
solutions
uh 24 7 and proof of stake is a much
more energy efficient alternative
there's also sharding which is a layer
one scaling solution
that says that instead of
every node in the network having to
download and process
everything every node in the network
only has to download and process a small
portion of all of the data
yeah the blockchain protocol is designed
in a clever way that
still ensures enough safety despite
having that constraint
so think of it as you know like
combining at least some of the
advantages of uh you know a bitcoin
style blockchain and bittorrent right
like bittorrent
is very layer one scale like there's
there's nobody who downloads um you know
every
movie or even like an index of every
movie yeah so before we get to layer two
so so
layer one is you're saying it's proof of
stake which is moving from proof of work
to proof of stake
and uh sharding which is breaking it
into pieces and having uh you know
different pieces do different things and
then try to reconcile them
on the proof of stake side i mean that
itself is a whole big debate that could
take up the entire podcast
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show
this episode is brought to you by
wealthfront did you know
if you missed 10 of the best performing
days after the 2008 crisis you would
have missed out on 50
5-0 percent of your returns don't miss
out on the best days in the market
stay invested in a long-term automated
investment portfolio wealthfront
pioneered the automated investing
movement sometimes referred to as robo
advising
and they currently oversee 20 billion
dollars of assets for their clients
wealthfront can help you diversify your
portfolio minimize fees and lower your
taxes
takes about three minutes to sign up and
then wealthfront will build you a
globally diversified portfolio of etfs
based on your risk appetite and manage
it for you at an incredibly low cost
wealthfront software constantly monitors
your portfolio day in and day out so you
don't have to
they look for opportunities to rebalance
and tax loss harvest to lower the amount
of taxes you pay on your investment
gains
their newest service is called autopilot
and it can monitor any checking account
for excess cash to move into savings or
an investment account
they've really thought of a ton they've
checked a lot of boxes
smart investing should not feel like a
roller coaster ride let the
professionals do the work for you
go to wealthfront.com tim and open a
wealthfront investment account today
and you'll get your first five thousand
dollars managed for free for life that's
wealthfront.comtim
wealthfront will automate your
investments for the long term and you
can get started today
at wealthfront.com tim
so the proof of work i'm familiar with
proof of stake could we just define
what that means the core idea basically
is
that any decentralized consensus system
where you know you don't have a central
registry that keeps track of you know
who the different humans are you need
some way for people to like basically
vote on
like which blocks go and which
transactions got included in the network
and you need for that vote to be secure
against
what's called a civil attack a civil
attack is when one attacker just
pretends to have one million different
accounts
normally like uh in you know like reddit
and like google accounts and twitter and
all of these centralized systems
like this is done using centralized
mechanisms right like
they sometimes require phone number
verification and then phone numbers
themselves some often
end up having some kind of kyc on top of
them there's
various kind of ai techniques that try
to detect bots
but in a decentralized system that you
know we don't have this set of
centralized registry of
who gets to be an actual user right and
we don't want to have that
and so to prevent this civil attack
right to prevent
one person from just generating a
billion accounts and out voting everyone
else
the solution is economics right the
solution is basically
that the extents to which you can vote
on
just this very limited question of which
transactions get included in what order
is proportional to
how many economic resources you put in
so in the case of proof of work
those economic resources come in the
form of computing
hardware that you're running right like
when you're running
um this mining software on your computer
you're cranking out these hash solutions
every hash solution
gives you the right to generate a block
and the number of hash solutions that
you can generate is proportional to how
many computers you put in
in proof of stake it works a little
differently
but the core principle is that your
ability to kind of participate in
creating the outcome
is proportional to how many coins that
are in the system that you're staking
and so the reason why proof stake is
efficient is because in proof of work
like the way that you are basically
prove that you have a computer to the
system
is by just like running the software on
on that computer 24 7 and generating
hash solutions right
like that's the only way to safely do it
because if you
did not have to run the computer 24 7
like if you only had to run in 12.7 well
then
you know you could have one computer
that just pretends to be two different
computers
but with proof of stake if you have
coins those coins are saved in an
account
that account has an associated public
and private key and you can just make a
digital signature with a private key so
you don't have to
like run any computer for longer than a
few milliseconds
that's the kind of core principle that's
supremely helpful thank you
yeah this is beyond the scope of this
podcast but
it is actually hotly debated how much
more efficient proof of stake is because
there's also
these blockchains they have to issue
coins to
in exchange for the security uh to the
so-called miners or validators in the
case of proof of stake and
people will you know spend a dollar to
get a dollar so to speak if you're
giving out free coins on the blockchain
then people are going to hustle in any
which way possible and in proof of work
they'll do it by
buying more computing equipment to run
more hashes to get the new coins coming
out and proof of stake
they'll have to lock up funds or they'll
have to obtain funds to do it there's a
cost to doing that to obtaining those
funds so there's no real free lunch
but there are arguments for efficiency
with proof of stake especially as you
get securing very large amounts
the way that i would just briefly
summarize the state case there is that
like proof of stake can actually survive
at least you know in the opinion of
group stake supporters with much
lower rewards than a proof of work can
and the reason is and
like because of how proof of stake works
the ratio between
the cost of attacking a system and the
cost of just running it like becomes uh
like more favorable but you know this is
a long debate um
i've written on it i have a post on
vitalik.ca
but if you just scroll down the most
recent one called proof of stake and
then you know proof of
work proponents have their own posts as
well so encourage you to read all of
them so going back so this is all layer
one scaling switch from proof of work to
proof of stake
uh start sharding the blockchain and
this gets you some
tens of times improvement like you know
20 times 25 times
improvement and through 100 times 100
times fantastic yeah so then there's
layer 2 which stacks on top
yes so layer two as i mentioned is about
creating protocols that live on top of
the blockchain that only use the
blockchain
in very particular ways so there's lots
of techniques for this right like
the simplest layer to to explain i think
is a very special purpose kind of lawyer
too called a payment channel
so the idea behind the payment channel
is like let's say
i am you know selling
you neval and um internet connection and
you're paying me per megabyte let's say
you're paying me you know like one cent
per megabyte
now if we want to do this over the
blockchain the naive way to do it is
every time a megabyte of data passes
through the connection
you will just make an unchained
transaction and you send me one cent
the problem is this requires lots and
lots of transactions
and the transaction fees are actually
much more expensive than one cent
so it's just completely economically
non-viable so here's what we do instead
you put ten dollars into
a smart contract right so you send ten
dollars on the blockchain to an address
where according to the rules of the
ethereum network once those funds are at
that address those funds are controlled
not by a human but by a computer program
and
that computer program will then have
some rules that i'll explain later
right so at the beginning you send 10
dollars to this contract
and so far you actually haven't made any
payments because
as i'll explain the gas contract has
rules that will allow you to get your
money out
now here's what you do after one
megabyte um after
you know we have one megabyte worth of
internet data passing between us
you create an off chain message and you
digitally signed that offstring message
that just has the number one sent um
just written on it
right so you will just write the you
know the number one cent
and you attach your signature and you
send this to me
none of this goes on chain then one more
megabyte happens
you write out a digital message that has
the number two cents
and you additionally sign it you send it
to me oh sometime later
every time a megabyte happens you just
send me one more of these messages and
you keep on incrementing the number
and let's say after a few hours of this
in total
we've had 347 megabytes so worth of
communication
and you've sent me a message that says
3.47
and you are now like no longer wants to
use my internet you know you're signing
off for the day
and so you know we're done so now here's
what happens
i can then take your message
and your message that says 3.47
i can attach my own signature to it and
i can publish it as a transaction
going to the smart contract and you have
your ten dollars in
the smart contract has a rule that says
if
i send one of your off-chain messages i
i call them tidbits if i send one of
your tickets if i kind of wrap one of
your tickets in an actual transaction
and i actually kind of publish your
ticket to the blockchain
then whatever amount of money is on your
ticket
goes to me and the remainder gets
refunded to you right so i get my three
dollars 47 cents
and you get your six dollars and 53
cents back
now it's actually incentive aligned
right because
um i um always have the ability to
use the most expensive ticket that use
the most recent ticket that you sent me
and i don't really have any reason to
use one of your older tickets right so
i'm always going to pick your later
ticket and so
i'm always going to claim all of the
money that i'm owed and you get your
money back
now if i disappear then after some
period of time
you have the ability to uh just to go in
and take the money back for yourself
right so the idea is that it's this
contraption where you know
in reality you've made a payments to me
347 times
right like you we've had 347
interactions during which
the amount of money that's entitled to
me goes up and the amount of money
that's entitled to you go down
but actually there's only two um actual
blockchain uh transactions that
uh are visible to and needs to be
processed by the rest of the network
right so
we make 347 payments but the blockchain
only sees two of them and that's you
know a factor of
178. uh two improvement there
yeah so so if i can summarize this for a
second uh right for kind of our
listeners
um basically what you're saying is let's
say that you and i have a long-lived
contract for some service rather than
publishing
every little aspect of that contract
under the ethereum blockchain and
flooding it
we go off to the side we do a whole
series of transactions but every time we
do a transaction
each of us like stamp it and say yeah
that little piece was done
and we update the transaction between
the two of us and then when we're
finished either one of us can go back to
the blockchain and submit the
the record of all the transactions and
say look it's signed by both of us so
this is valid e but
either one of us can submit it and the
blockchain executes it
so the blockchain only needs to know
when we left with how much money
staked on this transaction and when we
came back and what the total change was
it doesn't need to keep track of all the
intermediate pieces exactly yes that's a
good summary
now channels are like i think there's
the simplest
um kind of layer two but they're also
the least powerful layer two
they can only do payments they have a
hard time doing many kinds of smart
contracts
channels exist and they are being used
for more and more things um and
uh they're great but the thing that the
ethereum ecosystem is the most excited
about is something called roll-ups
now i don't want to actually you know go
in and fully explain rollups because
they're even more complicated than
channels
but for those who are interested i do
have an article um once again you know
go to vitalik.ca
scroll down like uh i think it's called
an incomplete guide to rollups
and so i described channels and also
this thing called plasma then also
roll-ups
and roll-ups are really powerful because
they can support not just payments they
can support
the full generality of applications like
exactly the same applications that you
can run directly on the ethereum
blockchain itself
but if you do those things inside a
rollup they become 100 times
cheaper so it's this very powerful
scalability technology
and the ethereum community loves rollups
because
they're very easy to upgrade to because
if you run an application on ethereum
you can just run the exact same
application inside of
an ethereum virtual machine compatible
roll-up of which
a couple of projects exist and actually
i think a couple of days ago optimism
uh announced that they're going to
launch their mainnet fairly soon
yeah roll ups are fascinating i've been
looking into them a little bit and
uh they're worth learning about it's
basically the idea is just that
there's these very complex machines that
are not on the blockchain that are off
the blockchain that are running the
transactions
but then they're submitting different
kinds of proofs back to the blockchain
to say
don't worry this was a valid transaction
and the two different approaches
optimism is optimistic where basically
optimistic roll-ups say we assume people
are doing the right thing
but we're watching and if someone
commits fraud or makes a mistake
then they get punished for that fraud
whereas there are these uh
zero-knowledge-based roll-ups you know
pioneered by starkware and others which
are basically saying
hey actually we're going to submit
proofs which are much shorter than the
actual computation that the computation
was done properly
but i think these give together what
another 100x speed up
yes so if you combine the eth2 layer one
speed up and the
layer two uh roll up speed up then you
get the ten thousand times speed up
exactly you can get like some somewhere
over one hundred thousand transactions a
second and
one other really nice uh feature of uh
sharding by the way is that like it's a
quadratic right so
if the efficiency of computers increases
by factor of two
then like you the you can support twice
as many
shards and each shard can be twice as
large and so
your the capacity of the whole system
increases by factor of four right and so
we actually expect
that capacity to increase like going
even far beyond 100
000 over you know the next couple of
decades so
is it a stretch to say then that it
would that sharding that sharding
increases capacity is a square of
moore's law
as opposed to justin moore's law yes
that this is
now if we get to a hundred thousand plus
transactions per second that's a lot i
mean to give a
given uh comparable metric there's a
there's about a hundred thousand tweets
per second at twitter during peak times
and obviously these transactions are
going to be much more sophisticated than
or could be much more sophisticated
in a single tweet they can actually be
arbitrary computer programs
running on the side so that's quite a
bit of scalability so so then i think
the question
comes up well well where is it you know
a lot of people i know who are building
apps on top of eth
have now had to come up with backup
plans there are competitive blockchains
that are coming up
which trade off decentralization
security for speed
so what they'll do is they'll say well
we'll only have 20 validators run by our
friends or maybe like 100 people that we
know and trust
but in exchange it's a lot faster like
now we don't have to get consensus from
unknown people all over the internet we
don't need these complicated
contraptions
and then they can basically run much
faster so a number of projects are
looking at these as
as backup plans but i know that they
don't necessarily want to use these
because these are less decentralized
they don't really fully live up to the
original promise of blockchains to the
same extent
so the real question i think in
everybody's mind is like is there a
timetable for these
you know can we can we reliably target a
date for certain kinds of improvements
because people are betting their
businesses on this
great and the very important question uh
so i mean i'll start off with
the progress of youth too so i think
it's important to reiterate because i
think a lot of people haven't
fully absorbed this the eth2 chain is
already running right so there's already
a proof of stake chain
uh it does not yet have sharding but the
proof of stake system is running
the thing that that has not yet happened
is um the event that we call the merge
which is where we basically
actually take on the existing activity
on ethereum and we fully move it over
from the proof of work chain to the
proof of stake chain
and then the proof of work changes that
basically becomes irrelevant from there
the reason why we took this kind of
multi-step approach where we first start
the proof of stake system and then
you know we let both run in parallel for
some time and then we merge at the end
is just to give proof of stake some time
to prove itself before the
entire ecosystem is asked to um upgrade
over you know the proof stake
thing exists it's been stable you're
running um ever since cell launch
and at some point fairly soon like
you know we are going to actually go and
merge all
all of the proof of work activity onto
it um so shorting
is um also going to happen um and
sharding right now is in the there's a
spec there's prototypes of parts of it
i will admit that we were actually
prioritizing the merge
kind of even more than shortening
recently the reason why for this
actually has to do with the other thing
which is rollups right
like the thing to remember is that if
you have rollups but you do not have
sharding
you still have 100x factor scaling right
you still have
the ability for the blockchain to go up
to somewhere between 1000 and 4000
transactions a second
depending on how complex these
transactions are
and so with rollups as i mentioned
the optimism you know fully evm capable
roll up is
likely to um launch an initial
maintenance release
some in around a month or so um there's
also a project called arbitrum
which is also an evm capable roll up
there is actually
simpler roll-ups that are only capable
of
processing simple transactions and
exchanging between assets
like loopring and zk-sync and those
roll-ups have already been running
stably for about a year right so rollups
aren't even theory they've been
a practical part of scalability of
ethereum for a few users for
almost a year and the thing that's left
is basically taking that same model and
just fully extending it to kind of not
just support transactions but also
arbitrary applications right so roll-ups
are coming very soon
and we're fully confident um that
by the time that we need any more
scaling than that
that you know sharding will have already
been um
ready for a long time by then so you're
basically saying fully
very confident that something like uh
you know an optimism or a
zk based rollup will be solving a 100x
scalability problem within the next few
months
i think so i mean i think um like
there's definitely a lot of people who
are not going to be comfortable moving
over just because you know it's new
technology and new technology always has
risks
but i expect there will be plenty of
applications and possibly even
non-financial applications like the
nifties and you know domain names and so
forth to start off just because
like the risks are lower if things do
break and then kind of creeping up to
higher and higher value things as people
become more comfortable over time
so do you think that ethereum could have
a scaling schism like bitcoin did
bitcoin split famously into bitcoin and
bitcoin cash over the block size debate
a few years back which is all around
scaling
and people some people were saying
bitcoin should be digital cash and so
therefore it needs these big blocks and
it needs to
handle more transactions and other
people said no no bitcoin is a swiss
bank account it's digital gold
and it needs to be secure and lots of
small nodes have to be able to run it so
we care more about security
than we do about handling small
transactions and the
the small block people won and so
bitcoin forked
and now of course what we call bitcoin
is a small block bitcoin that won that
debate
do you think that there's a possibility
that miners some miners and people will
stay on eth1 instead of eth2
i think so except i do think that
the risks are much lower a big part of
the reason why is because we've been
very open
about proof of stake and sharding being
the vision basically from the first day
and ethereum did already have the schism
right of ethereum
and ethereum classic and uh a lot of the
proof-of-work
proponents did actually move over the to
ethereum classic already because they
recognized that you know ethereum
classic community and ideology was one
that's more aligned with
continuing proof of work forever and so
you know why
um stay on the chain where the core
developers and lots of people are
eagerly expecting a prostate change if
you can just move on to a platform
already that
kind of accepts your values um so i
think that was one of the factors that
did
um actually end up making the e3
transition
kind of a bit more secure um another
thing
also is that i don't really think
there's a deep schism of ideologies
within
ethereum in the way that there wasn't
bitcoin right like i think in ethereum
everyone is roughly on board with the
idea that you know you have some layer
one scaling and you have some weird two
scaling
there are some kind of longer term
disagreements like uh
like you know justin drake one of our
researchers for example is much more
into
making layer one more powerful whereas
i'm more in favor of a simpler lawyer
one
and um having layer two is do more
things
that's not a kind of extremely deep and
fundamental disagreement but like you
know either approach is
gonna have lots of scalability and it's
gonna deliver a
great uh environment sets for
ethereum users so that's interesting you
don't you don't even really run ethereum
you have disagreements with developers
and they could even change it in a way
that you don't like has that happened
yet has has there been a case where
something has been implemented into
ethereum
that maybe the community or the other
developers wanted which you sort of
disagreed with
there's definitely been changes that
i have wanted to push forward that
i mean i gave up on fairly quickly
because i know
enough court developers or the community
ended up
disagreeing on them there's been changes
that were kind of pushed forward by
some people who are not myself and then
where i just kept completely silenced so
like blog reward decreases um for
example i was completely silent
or mostly silenced brock powell was
mostly silent as hell it was obvious
that the brockport side was
losing things that i was trying to
push forward i mean those are harder to
find just because like
i tend to just naturally understand what
the community what it would accept
and i don't really try to push things
that
i don't think would be successful i mean
there's like
some minutiae around um you know scaling
strategies
and uh statelessness and state
management strategies where
myself and some other core developers
have some different opinions and so
there's a lot of back and forth where we
try to sort of satisfy each other's
concerns
yeah my sense from afar is you're more
coordinating than dictating
and you're doing what are you running
the ethereum foundation is there an
organization you're part of or are you
just kind of a roving individual with a
laptop and a few
friends who just kind of writes blog
posts and submits
uh proposals i mean some of both and i
do you know
i do the proposal submitting i have do
you know some
some writing proof of concepts um and
you know in python i
do some kind of trying to coordinate
people
the ethereum foundation as an
organization exists so the executive
director of that
is um ayamiya gucci and she has been
doing a lot of the logistical things for
about the past
three years and has done an amazing job
and you know i end up
uh you know coordinating and working
with her quite a lot on
uh various things but even the ethereum
foundation like
it has an important role because it has
this kind of a large pool of capital
and this kind of high level of kind of
public legitimacy but it's uh
not nearly the only organization within
ethereum right like there's
a lot of proposals that got initiated on
the outside
there's a lot of proposals that
got a really huge amount of community
support coming from the outside
even organizations other than the
ethereum foundation that have a lot of
resources within the ethiopian ecosystem
so like for example
for the first few years consensus um did
quite a lot
in consensus is still doing a lot but
now there's also a uniswap
whose treasury has just grown a huge
amount and they here
are even wealthier than the ethereum
foundation is so
it i think in practice it does end up
being this kind of loose collaborative
effort between a lot of different
different groups
so uni-swap is interesting uniswap is uh
for those of you don't know it's an
application
built on top of ethereum but it has its
own token and it's the
it's a one of the first uh automated
market makers a decentralized platform
for exchanging cryptocurrencies with
each other without having to use a
centralized authority like a coin base
or a gemini or a coin list instead you
just go on to
you go to unit swap and it's a smart
contract it's not owned or run by
anybody except the community and a few
developers and there's a token
associated with it
but you can just automatically trade
with this smart contract to turn say
your ethereum into a stable coin
to get the equivalent of dollars or back
this shows how the ethereum ecosystem is
very different than the bitcoin
ecosystem in the bitcoin ecosystem
there's only one coin there's bitcoin
and they don't really tolerate other
tokens in their orbit
whereas with ethereum you have a lot of
other tokens in the orbit and
you'll see blockchains that are
competing with ethereum that are trying
to
you know they're making different
trade-offs and you know whether it's
flow or
ava or near or whatever there's a whole
bunch of those but then there's also
people who are built on top of you
like balancer and curve and unit swap
and whatnot and so
what's your view on all these other
tokens how many tokens are there going
to be
how do you determine which one makes
sense and which one doesn't and do other
blockchains make sense at layer one or
should other tokens only emerge at layer
two now that ethereum exists
now this is definitely a very important
topic
tokens are one of those uh things that's
really like playing with fire right like
on the other hand
um fire is that crucial to human
civilization but on the
other hand fire is uh if you're evil you
can burn up your family if you're not
careful
so the the thing with tokens right is
that
the crypto space is not the only space
that tried
to build decentralized things right like
there are a lot of decentralized
projects that are outside the crypto
space like um
diaspora the decentralized alternative
to facebook the people tried to build
around 2010
is one good example but the challenge
with um
this kind of pre-blockchain or
non-blockchain decentralization or
crypto is that
it's harder to kind of align the
incentives and motivate people to
actually
wants to participate in you know
building and growing the community at a
large scale
like you can get idealists but the
problem with idealism is that
idealism is not very socially scalable
cryptocurrency on the other hand um you
know can
uh appeal to the kind of universal
values right like where
you know the real universal value is
getting rich for a lot of people
yeah and it seems with ethiopia you've
done a bit of both you've got a bit of
both you've got people
who have ether getting rich and then
there's also a movement yeah
right exactly and i like i think that
balance is important right like i think
the failure of a lot of non-blockchain
crypto shows
the uh inability to do things at scale
without that financial incentive but at
the same time
you know the project a lot of the more
at least in my opinion amoral
projects within crypto that just care
about uh you know
the pump and uh the volume and um you
know
getting a powerful and expensive token
that they can get rich off of like
those projects end up not really doing
well in the long term either right and
there's been
plenty of projects where just like vc
funds gave
you know hundreds of millions of dollars
of capital to them but you know the
reality is that like
hundreds of millions of dollars of
capital just can't buy you a soul
right and so a lot of people end up
kind of stumbling and falling on that to
some extent
yeah i think some of that is just driven
by the pre-mine phenomenon
where bitcoin had a so-called fair
launch although you can debate how fair
it was
but you know how far the distribution is
today but uh
everyone sort of started mining at the
same time or everyone who was aware of
it
whereas a lot of coins that have come
subsequently the team has a pre-mine
where they get a bunch of
the coin in advance and as the amount of
the pre-mine goes up and the competition
moves from
hey let's mine as much bitcoin as
possible to hey let's just create the
winning blockchain and then get the big
pre-mine
so it's just move the competition from
mining to creating or forking
uh so it's almost sort of inevitable
once pre-mines became a little bit
accepted that there would be so many
different blockchains
yeah no i think that's uh definitely
fair too
like ethereum once again it's kind of
fairly
kind of moderate there like there was a
free mine but you know the pre-mine was
only about 12
percent of actually about 10 of the
total supply
and you know people did have the
opportunity to mine or to combine the
sale and so a lot of people had the
opportunity to kind of become part of
the ecosystem
but i mean i do think that you know the
less monetary kind of the movement
aspects of this is important right like
if you're just um you know go to coin
market cap and you look at
some of the like top 10 coins
other than like say bitcoin and ethereum
but you can't always give a good answer
for
you know what values does that token
represent whereas you know for bitcoin
you can for a theorem you can for z cash
for example
i think you can so i think there
definitely is this
kind of a complicated balance between
different factors
basically the coin can help but too much
emphasis on the um
on just the coin can hurt and it's
challenging
i think uniswap actually did really well
with their coin
because uh like on the one hand you know
you could kind of criticize it and say
you know oh this was only just a measure
that it was kind of reactionary that was
reacting to you know kind of sushi swap
trying to kind of swoop in and uh
basically try to push everyone to
quickly migrate over and they had a coin
and so people
you know got into sushi swap because
they just wanted to get rich off of it
and so unislop reacted by making their
own coin
um but at the same time like they did
this one really cool thing which has
a big part of the initial distribution
was this very
uh kind of egalitarian air drop right
like basically
if you had used the eunice swap
even once before the air drop began
you would get 400 unit tokens so at the
time those uh uni tokens were worth
about three and a half dollars and so
the joke was like
you know unislop actually delivered on
giving everyone a stimulus check
and uh you know people really loved that
and uh
you know the the supply distribution
distribution of uni was again very
widely dispersed
and the whole thing was this kind of dao
where a lot of people could uh
participate in decision making so i
think
like there's ways to do tokens while
there's ways to do tokens poorly
yeah the backdrop on unit swap uh sushi
swap is unit swap was this automated
market maker this decentralized exchange
that launched
and then they sort of got attacked they
got cloned by this other one called
sushi swap you know joking uni sushi
and then they tried to like steal the
unisoft community by saying hey come
here and we'll pay you more
by giving you tokens and then unisa was
forced to actually create a token
which we then gave away to their
community which are called airdrops it's
like helicopter drops of money except
now it's made up tokens
so there's all this interesting stuff
that goes on in crypto where
trying to build and maintain communities
you have to figure out how to
distribute the spoils but contrast how
this is compared to say facebook or
twitter
you don't see mark zuckerberg air
dropping facebook stock on the users and
you don't see jack dorsey
air dropping twitter revenues and the
users but that's exactly what happens in
blockchain land
and you know ethereum might have had a
small pre-mine but i do remember
early on looking at ethereum and i think
i i talked to biology srinivasan one of
your other guests about it tim
where we were looking at eth back in the
day when it was first launching and we
were just really confused because it
seemed like there was this one brilliant
technical guy surrounded by like 15
other people who all had the title
co-founder
and it was very confusing to evaluate as
an investor so we ended up not investing
to our detriment
but that's that's my way of saying that
this was not a vitalik get-rich-quick
scheme i don't think vitalik even had
you know was even the single largest
token holder i think there were
many other people who frankly you know
had a lot less to do with ethereum
success who ended up holding a huge
number of tokens so to the extent that
vitalik is the one who's working on it
and pushing it forward it's a labor of
love and i've always been super
impressed by how his team is very
altruistic and really kind of wants to
make the world a better place
maybe they're young and naive but it's
you know it's refreshing to see that so
i think
you know in terms of branding a lot of
people look at ethereum as like
lift to bitcoin's uber right there's
sort of a crypto right-wing
libertarianism versus a crypto left-wing
uh sort of libertarianism now let me
jump in for one second here if i
may ask a naive question or a novice
question maybe
and if if i'm completely looking at this
the wrong way i'd love to be corrected
uh thinking of ethereum
and comparing it to say bitcoin and
considering the possible regulatory
threats
to bitcoin and i think probably a
a stronger focus on cryptocurrency than
blockchain
by regulators and just by extension if
we're thinking of
ethereum on some level as both
cryptocurrency but also as a world
computer
maybe as if amazon had its own
cryptocurrency right bezonians or
whatever
whatever they might call it and then aws
that even if there were a crackdown on
currencies
that ethereum would have some
resilience and anti-fragility in that
respect does it mean
that ethereum in its entirety
is less subject to regulatory threat
or that it can thrive in the face of
regulatory
threat along the lines of that which uh
bitcoin could face
i mean comparing the enough regulatory
situation of uh ethereum and bitcoin i
mean i think
like both benefit from being highly
international right like bitcoin has a
strong community in the us and has a
strong community in china it has a
strong community and you know the eu and
lots of other places
ethereum is very similar in that regard
you know there's these very strong
communities and lots of
different countries you know including
countries that are
uh you know not kind of geopolitically
on the same age with each other
so there's a lot of i mean of resiliency
yeah
in that sense now of course the
other kind of aspect of uh
politics is that like it's not
just about what they can do it's also
about like what they want to do
the reality is that regulators have
cracks down on
cryptocurrencies significantly less than
they
theoretically could right like they
theoretically could like make something
like one basically go overnight
right and like i think the reality is
that
you know they yeah don't uh in part
because like they do see a lot of the
positive
value that's uh coming out of these
platforms right
and there's even regulators that wants
to use
you know public blockchains and i you
know even things like ethereum to build
applications on top of them you know
they get
see value in some of the kind of
advantages that the things like stable
coins for example could provide or
even you know non-financial applications
of various kinds
yeah if you wanted to build a
fraud-proof voting application you'd
probably do it in ethereum
yeah cryptocurrencies are inherently
designed to be sovereign resistant right
they're they're designed to be stateless
and so the geographic redundancy is one
aspect of it and
some countries try to ban it like i
think uh for a while
people think china tried to ban it and
that sort of failed and right now
india is talking about banning it and
that will end in tears right that's not
going to go well when you leave your
country out of the
innovation the next 10 years so
hopefully they don't do that but there's
also redundancy in terms of design
for example going to proof of stake is a
different kind of redundancy than being
just all proof of work
so you're not subject to the same kinds
of attacks i think being used for
all kinds of applications now could you
speak to that
yeah so proof of work is you shut down
minors and minors of hardware and
equipment you know where they live
right they need a physical presence
whereas proof of stake is validators we
just need an internet connection
and so they're kind of harder to stop
and harder to find in theory
and then you also have just what
applications are running
on top of these platforms so if you're
just running digital gold that's one
application but if you're also running
as vitalik said
uh you know functioning prediction
markets public goods
uh financial systems voting systems
gaming systems
nifty tokens art galleries right and all
those kinds of things then
it gets very hard to shut it down and i
actually think eventually
all internet traffic will be encrypted
and all of it will require
cryptocurrencies to kind of just
allocate scarce resources like even
today there are things that we do on the
internet that are centralized like
caching and routing and
spam filtering that should be
decentralized and involve crypto
payments for efficiency
and once we sort of start getting to
those applications it'll be very hard to
turn off
crypto without turning off the internet
it's the native money of the internet
and so if you take away value transfer
from the internet the internet as we
know it
will be stunted at best and more likely
just cease to function at some levels
thank you back to you yeah oh yeah yeah
no not at all no
yeah it's i mean there's there's there's
there's an infinite number of
rabbit holes we can go down coming back
to ethereum for a second so there's
bitcoin
which is clearly digital gold there's
ethereum which is the world computer
and you know with digital gold high
price is good you want your gold to go
up in value except to the extent these
days digital gold bitcoin has been going
up
but it actually gives me some
trepidation i tell people it's like my
insurance policy is becoming more
valuable
my life insurance policy right i don't
know how i feel about that
but with eth it's not clear the price
going up is always that good for
adoption it's it's good for the people
who are pumping and holding
but is it so good for the people who are
trying to use it i mean well
do you have any thoughts on the price of
ethan how much for example we don't even
know
exactly how much if there is going to be
the future right the supply curve is a
little bit undefined
and some people say oh it could be too
big this thing will get inflated
whereas the other arguments say no there
are certain applications we're going to
have for which you have to lock up ether
or even destroy
eth to use these applications so each
may end up being more valuable do you
have a
what is your current point of view and
where the east supply heads and what the
eth price means for the ecosystem
yeah so one thing that i think you
alluded to a little bit
is that there's this proposal called
eip1559 which
kind of redesigns how the transaction
fee market works and
you know there's a lot of kind of very
wonky a kind of economic
math for um kind of why the specific
changes that it makes that makes sense
but one of the consequences of that
change
is that the majority of fees instead of
going to the miner whoever creates the
block would get burned like it would
just literally get deleted out of
existence
and so if demands to use ethereum is
high enough uh then
there would actually be more east than
uh they're being destroyed than is being
created and so you know the the joke
that shows sometimes make is you know if
bitcoin know if uh fix supplies sound
money then you know if you have a
decreasing supply does that make us some
ultrasound money
and it actually is not even that far
fetched the possibility like if you look
at
the transaction fees for the last month
like they actually have been on
a lot of days greater than the yeah
block rewards for that
for that day um so it's interesting
because like it basically
creates this more direct connection
between people using the ethereum
blockchain
and um you know eth having some value
right like um at the beginning the way
that eth was even described when we were
doing the sale is that this is like
gas you know you're buying this token
that you needs to use
and if you want to expense transactions
and
if the token is actually a consumable
right then it actually behaves even more
like um
well i guess you know gasoline as the
original metaphor right like
if people wanted to use it they would
actually have to consume it and so
the value of it is actually something
that kind of depends
on the ethereum network being useful
and let's say yeah like it's a bit of a
different um kind of
guiding principle than something like
bitcoin right where bitcoin
just derives value from you know bitcoin
the currency drops value from bitcoin
the currency and bitcoin the blockchain
is this kind of
thing often decide that well okay fine
it has to exist
whereas in ethereum like it's much more
of a system worth of watching is the
point
um and you know the east the asset gains
value from the blockchain um
doing its uh its job successfully that's
interesting so
bitcoin the value is in the currency or
in the bitcoin itself whereas in eth
the value is in the blockchain being
used and the eth is the byproduct of it
yeah to use my strained castles made of
math analogy
you know i i i think it is bitcoin is
like the big
impregnable citadel the fort knox into
which you're putting your gold
and you and that thing has high walls
and is guarded really well and they
don't change much and
you know it's the same as it was in 2009
or 2011 so that no one can break in
but eth is sort of this dynamic network
of little city states that are trading
with each other so the more trade there
is the more free flow of information and
goods the more valuable the whole system
becomes
but no single point of it is necessarily
as impregnable
like for example i do expect that we'll
see more hacks and break-ins and
failures in the ecosystem
as a whole not an eth itself but in the
ecosystem around eth
than we will in the ecosystem around
bitcoin necessarily
but at the same time eth is dynamic and
growing and adaptive
which just makes it more of a you know
an evolving creature
yeah and i i'd agree with that with one
reservation which is that i mean
i think the bitcoin ecosystem does have
its own uh kind of taking time bomb
demons too
um like a tether is one example yeah
there are pieces around the bitcoin
ecosystem that are
semi-centralized or on of unknown
trustworthiness
uh and do rely on uh untrusted untrusted
third parties i should say
uh but you know as the bitcoin people
say like not your keys not your coin
right right and trusted third parties or
security holes
um so they're aware of that i think the
the bitcoin maximalist which i believe
is a term that you co-coined
um the bitcoin maximalists uh would say
well that's not bitcoin right that's
something else
um so i mean one of the things to think
about here and i think you care about
this more than most people in crypto
which is nice is that
you do seem to care about wealth
inequality the genie coefficient and the
distribution of coins
and one of the criticisms about crypto
that i see a lot is like well okay so
you're getting rid of the old oligarchs
with this new financial system
but you're just replacing them with new
oligarchs who are the original bitcoin
and eth holders
and how do you think about the
distribution of wealth in a crypto
run economy as opposed to a fiat
currency uh aka the u.s dollar
and uh you know the euro-run economy
this is definitely
one i think one of the challenging kind
of questions for
the the community to grapple with um and
this is actually one of the reasons
um why i kind of really like ethereum's
uh kind of
more you know multi-currency welcoming
ecosystem right like
you know sure okay you have eth and uh
you know there's
a yeah limited set of opportunities to
kind of get you if directly from the tap
and at some points uh
you know the supply is going to
stabilize and if you're buying ether
just
you're buying it from a previous people
but at the same time there are these new
applications that are launching you know
you have your um
uni as i mentioned where the
distribution was
i mean i thought quite egalitarian right
like the as i mentioned you know the
the 400 um uni stimulus checks that just
go to everyone who
ever used the application at least once
and they could
try really hard to not favor wealthy
users too much
and then there's i think tornado cash
had an airdrop
a couple of weeks back uh there's
more of these assets coming in and i
think like that kind of
churn is um healthy like it you know it
breathes new life into the ecosystem
you know it brings a new life into the
wealth distribution and it does
create opportunities for new people to
be able to come in and kind of
participate
on a somewhat level footing as well but
then if we want to compare all of this
to the fiat ecosystem like it's a
difficult comparison to make just
because um you know the getting out of
institutions are so different and it's
kind of difficult to
you know match one up against the other
right like
fiat currency is you know they basically
get created by kind of a combination of
uh
you know the the central bank and to the
commercial banking and
ecosystem and in terms of where the
the kind of new newly generated value
comes in like you know both sides of
that gets uh
some share essentially and like there's
bad things that come out of it there's
also good things that come out of it
um so like i mean i know like this is a
controversial position among the
libertarians but like i actually like
the idea that
you know if you have a fiat currency
then the government can print it and
just use that as a source of government
revenue
and the reason why i like it is because
i think if the government can earn
can get money through unobtrusive means
that reduces the extent to which it has
to rely on
getting money through more intrusive
means and you know rely on
taxation and kind of more direct right
the problem is when it's unobtrusive
it's very easy to do it very sneakily
right and these tax taxes have to be
collected now whereas
uh printing can kick the can down the
road for the next person to solve
right right this is uh arguments in the
other direction yeah
there's a there's a moral hazard there
and i think we're watching it play out
where we printed eight trillion dollars
last year and who's gonna pay for it
right now the nice thing about
cryptocurrency of course is that like
the ecosystem is much more transparent
um and so you know it's easier to
analyze
and understand what the rules are and
like within the context of a crypto
ecosystem you know as i mentioned you
can still do very
egalitarian things um you can still you
know
reward people who were very important
early contributors to things that ended
up being very important um so
you know you can still do um
all of those things and you know we do
have a responsibility to get the balance
right
but the environment is just
inherently a more kind of open and
honest one just because you know these
are decentralized systems and everyone
does just they see exactly what's going
on
yeah it's certainly more transparent
like you can tell what the money supply
of ethers at any given point good luck
doing that with the us dollar money
supply or you can tell what the
inflation on youth is at any given point
and as you say there's opportunities to
build more applications in top of eath
and maybe eth is the app store for
decentralized applications but some of
those applications can go on to capture
just as much value
and create just as much value as eth
itself
so i think that'll be uh it the really
interesting development
in the last year is just to see
applications on top of eth
really creating and capturing and
building lots of wealth and
value and so in that sense this 2021
and 2020 run up seemed a little
different to me than 2017 run up which
was based on just
you know a lot of hype frankly um
so as we see sort of crypto playing out
you've also had
some very interesting thoughts on
everything from
radical markets to political philosophy
to kind of what happened in 2020 and so
on and we could spend a whole podcast on
that but
just at a very high level you had a
really good post on your blog saying
endnotes
on 2020 and it was about a lot more than
just crypto so what else are you really
interested in these days i mean
is it agi is it life extension is it
public goods is it different kinds of
voting schemes what's really on top of
mind for you that's not
directly crypto related some of all of
those
uh so like i think the changing uh kind
of way in which economics works is
definitely one of those really important
topics
there's a couple of different kind of
changes that's happening like one of
them that i talked about is just public
goods becoming more important right like
a lot of the ways that like people
thought of economics like 50 or 100
years ago they just that kind of focused
on private goods like
cars houses food you know things like
that
but there's also public goods right
which are
projects that benefit um
a large and unselective group of people
and so no
individual person who benefits um has
the incentive to personally funds the
whole thing
but it's hard to push people to pay for
it because like you can't
you know deny the benefits of the thing
to people who don't pay
for it for example right and so
scientific research is one example of a
public good
my blog is one example of a public good
open source software
is an example of a public good and like
on the internet public goods are even
more common
than private goods are uh and so like
our economics um just
has to uh you know just take that fact
seriously
and a lot of what's
been happening in the blockchain space
in some ways just is you know the crypto
world trying to grapple against those
things
so basically these public goods are
where the costs are concentrated like if
i want to
fund scientific research i do it out of
my own pocket but it benefits all of
humanity so the benefits are distributed
and so these tend to be under supply
they tend to be too few of them
and so there are there are schemes out
there to tackle some of them i think
you've talked about quadratic funding as
an example
yes what is quadratic funding
so quadratic funding is this um
interesting
mechanism that basically says anyone can
donate money to public goods through the
mechanism
but to compensate for this kind of under
provision that you talk about the
mechanism provides a subsidy
to every public good and that subsidy
depends not just on the amount that was
contributed but also on
the total number of people who
contributed right so like for example if
there's two projects
they both got a hundred dollars but one
of them got let's say 80 dollars from
one person and 20
from another person and the second
project just got one dollar from each of
100 people
the second public good is much more
public than the first public good
and the tragedy of the commons on the
second one is much greater
right and so the fact that the that the
second one managed to get to a hundred
dollars despite the 100 way tragedy of
the commons
implies that it's a really important
project and so the quadratic funding
mechanism actually
gives a much greater subsidy to the you
know one dollar from 100 each of 100
people project
um than it does from the project that
got just uh
a hundred dollars from um you know a
split between two people
and so we've been experimenting with the
quadratic funding
there's this uh thing called git coin
grants that happens a few times a year
uh and that's had about like seven
or um or eight rounds by now i forget
the exact number
um just for public goods within the
ethereum ecosystem and that's worked
really well
um so that's been one of the you know
interesting experiments that i've been
following
question on quadratic funding just to
hop in here since
i'm involved with a few different types
of scientific research
are those funders in those experiments
that you've run
anonymized or de-anonymized because i'm
thinking through the example you gave
and how there are
other plausible explanations for why
there might be
two funders i'm just thinking about for
instance reputational risk
associated with certain types of
scientific research
uh right there are other plausible
explanations but those largely
hinge on named names versus
them being anonymous so how do you think
about other contributing factors
depending on how you're conducting the
experiments sure
so first of all like in quadratic
funding unfortunately you do need to
have some kind of model of for identity
because
you know he needs to prevent the two
people from just pretending that they
are 100 people
right but with cryptography you actually
can do
fancy things that give you most of the
benefit from having anonymity despite
needing to have an identity system
basically
you can have a system where people can
make all these contributions
and they're you know done
in such a way that the system identifies
like how many unique contributors there
are for each project
but where the system does not get an
idea like nobody
actually gets any idea of exactly which
particular person
um donated how much money to which
particular project this is done
using this really important and
fascinating topic of a zero knowledge
proof cryptography
in zero knowledge proof cryptography
like basically
the idea is that it allows you to
make cryptographic proofs that some
statement is true
um so like i can make a cryptographic
proof that says that you know
i have 100 coins or that you signed a
message
that contains like some um some fact
about me and it was signed with your key
and you can make these proofs but where
the proof does not reveal the
contents of the thing that it's proving
right so like for example i can prove
that i have an account that has at least
100 coins
but i don't have to prove which account
it is i don't have to prove exactly how
many coins i have
and there's a lot of this very fancy
mathematical magic that basically
creates this protocol where if you give
me a proof
then i know that the statement is true
because if the statement is false you
would have had no way to generate the
proof
but if i have just the proof i can learn
nothing else beyond the fact that that
particular statement is correct
so this is incredibly powerful
cryptography it's uh
it's behind zcash for example there's
also with your end applications like
tornado cache um
that are using it there's zero knowledge
proofs also have these really nice
scalability proofs um so
the proofs are very quick to verify even
if the statement that they're proving is
incredibly complex
and zk roll ups like some of these
scaling solutions end up
really benefiting from using them so
very powerful technology and i think
it's also
very significant for me social
perspective because
you know we have this broader kind of
anonymity versus accountability debate
right
of like you know the benefits of privacy
versus the benefits of like basically
persistent reputations
and zero knowledge cryptography is
really powerful because
it may it's in a lot of cases allow us
to get
both good things at the same time like
you could get us the benefits of uh
the things like persistent reputations
while at the same time getting uh
a lot of the benefits of anonymity seems
very powerful
just to follow up on that thinking of
scientific
research i'm going to ask you what areas
you might have particular personal
interest in i know you have some
interest in
life extension uh as evidenced by the
the dragon slaying parable on your
website
or that you link to from your twitter
bio but it strikes me that
the quadratic funding experiments would
also be
heavily dependent on equally
simplistic or simplified communication
of competing not necessarily competing
but contrasted scientific studies right
because
there are some instances just in my
experience where
scientific studies that require a lot of
scientific knowledge or due diligence
would have fewer funders compared to
others but that doesn't necessarily
reflect
less importance or impact potential yes
now this is also a very important point
and i think the solution to this is that
like quadratic funding by itself doesn't
solve all the problems and you have to
combine quadratic finding with other
mechanisms
so i can give two examples one example
of how you could do this is you could
just
set up an organization where the
organization has some smart people
and you know those smart people do a
good job of picking who the
scientists are that are really worth
funding and then that organization gets
a five or ten year history
and people see that oh you know yes this
organization
does have a surprisingly good track
record of uh funding
you know the studies that actually do
end up turning out to be meaningful five
years down the line
and then people will just contribute
through the quadratic funding scheme to
this organization
and the organization be able to leverage
its own reputation
now if that organization ends up you
know doing bad things and abusing
um it's this kind of public trust that
it's earned then you know people could
very easily just stop contributing to it
and start contributing to it to another
group
so that's one approach another approach
is that there could be clever ways to
combine quadratic funding with venture
capital
so the idea here is that imagine if when
people make a public good
they create a coin associated with that
public good
and they just let people buy the coin
and when people buy the coin the
revenues just go to the people who issue
it and then
what you can do with quadratic funding
is you can basically
um kind of collectively buy out these
coins right so you can just say okay
you know this coin is a coin that
represents a project
that gave the world uh say a million
dollars worth of value and so we're
gonna quadratically find the million
dollars
into the coin and so anyone who bought
that coin would be able to benefit right
and
so the idea is that like if there are
intelligent
investors that are able to recognize
that something will be valuable
you know 10 years in the future then
like basically they will be able to make
a profit off of this and
if anyone has something that like is
maybe difficult for the
kind of wider public to determine is
valuable at the beginning
but then is likely to lead to some
important outcome that just everyone
recognizes is really valuable sometime
in the future
then you know kind of these investors
can fill the gap right so like you have
these two approaches like you can either
rely on reputation and kind of
uh do it retrospectively or you can rely
on
this kind of combination of quadratic
funding with um you know tokens and
investment to do it prospectively um
so i think uh both of those are really
interesting
i love this uh possibility to combine
also right i mean
you could potentially have all of the
elements that you described
combined and i know all you you sound
like you want to
jump in i was just thinking that the
campaign financing kind of works a
little bit like this
maybe accidentally maybe the system is
just navigated to it through kind of a
complex systems level intelligence but
if you look at
campaign financing for when people run
for office there's a maximum limit they
can get per
donor right and so an individual can
only gift a certain amount to a
congressman or to a
senator or presidential candidate and
then the feds also have matching funds
on top of that
so it's a combination of these schemes
because by limiting the amount that any
one person can give
you're sort of creating a quadratic
although it's not truly quadratic like i
you know someone very wealthy i guess
they could give a lot more through a
side vehicle but then that's less
efficient because they're not allowed to
coordinate with the main campaign
so there's kind of a really badly
implemented version of quadratic funding
with matching dollars already in
existence
in federal campaign financing that's a
good point
yeah uh yeah vitalik are what areas of
scientific
inquiry or research are on your short
list
of most personally interesting at the
moment
yeah so you brought up life extension
life extension is definitely really
important to me
um like i think in the coronavirus has
um actually even had the positive side
effect of uh kind of speeding this along
in some ways but
there's a lot of extremely promising
things happening in uh biotech
i think there's a very significant
chance that like where we're standing
today is basically
is for biotech the equivalent of where
computers were in 1950 right and so if
you imagine
you know the difference between the
eniac and um you know
like a modern kind of laptop or
smartphone that's the difference that
we're going to see
between the biotech of the 2020 and the
wyotech of 2090. and so
if right now we can already come up with
uh
vaccines for a virus well a year for
deployment to start but really the whole
the whole thing actually happens much
faster and uh
you know most of the delay can be blamed
on like bioconservatism but that's in a
whole other discussion
if you go from even there and then you
know add 70 years of progress to that
like it seems
it's very easy to see just even
the process of aging turning into
something that just becomes reversible
and it being
a regular thing for people to live um
you know
one and a half for two centuries and
then um go even further from there
there's just a huge kind of nice
humanitarian outcome that can come from
that
you know basically like the concept of
uh
your grandmother dying is just going to
kind of slowly
leave the public consciousness the same
way that the concept of getting lost in
a city
um slowly left the public consciousness
over the last 25 years as we got better
cell phones
and and i think that's a really lovely
and just kind of much better world to
spend a lot of resources to shoot for
do you think that's realistic though
given all the three letter agencies that
slow down experimentation and
development because
i worry it's more like nuclear power
right where they can't tolerate a single
death so the
innovation isn't really allowed right so
this is where i say a controversial
thing which is i think i'm very happy
that
the coronavirus has helped to
delegitimize bioconservatism to the
extent that it has
yeah i agree with that the modern
vaccine was ready on jan 13th
right yes and like even things like
human challenge studies right like
the defaults i think bioethics opinion
around a year ago i was like you know oh
my god this is unethical
and you know now like in the uk they're
actually happening no this is great
yeah no it is good if it breaks down
bioconservatism to some extent because
the pace of innovation is too low it's
like what we've done to nuclear power
if we do that to biotech and we kind of
have already to some extent but if we do
it even more then
there's no chance of you know grandma
living forever there's not even a chance
of me living
you know 50 years longer let alone
grandma living forever
um you know you're 27 i i'd love to see
where you're at 47. you're going to be a
you know really interesting guy you
already are but you're going to be an
even more interesting guy
even more interesting at 447. yeah
i hope you guys can both come to my
1000th birthday party
well are you are you on some kind of
caloric restriction or intermittent
fasting
um so so far i yeah well i do like the
poor man's intermittent fasting which is
that i just usually don't eat breakfast
i do again the usual exercise
nothing too fancy uh i eat
kind of at least a couple of the basic
supplements that the that the life
extension cool people are
recommending nothing too much fancier
than that so far
uh though you know very closely watching
the space and then i'm sure
i'll end up doing much more things so
you know like 10 or even 5 years from
now
do you take rapamycin i do not take
rapamycin um
metformin is the one that i take um
ashwagandha is another that i take
and just for those people listening who
who should know this number one this
none of this is medical advice number
two
uh metformin just as an example none of
these things should be taken without
advice of a medical professional
metformin is used in the treatment of
type 2 diabetes glucophage
but i'm also familiar with it how do you
decide what to
implement versus not implement for
yourself personally
um i just um and ask around a lot of
people in the life extension
community uh yeah you know read the
studies
uh yeah you know look at
just what are some of the high level
results um
and then just kind of narrow down to a
couple of things
it is remarkable how many people in
various sub communities have been
using a lot of these interventions
longitudinally i remember
when i was working on my second book
looking into
trans resveratrol and finding even at
that time this was 2008
2009 people who had for years been using
want to say 500 milligrams per day so
you were able to identify
certain long-term effects and side
effects
granted anecdotally but still having an
n of
i don't know maybe a thousand people on
this forum
so there is a lot to be gleaned uh from
these
from these groups yeah there's even a
new one making the rounds of glucagon
like peptides glp1 i'm sure you've seen
some study floating around on that
but yeah these things are very unknown i
wish these were more out in the open and
that
there was a very very strong anti-aging
research community that was functioning
out in the open that was trading notes
on what works and what doesn't and
able to run some kind of human trials
you know more efficiently
because uh fighting aging is a is a very
time sensitive task
it is yeah it's uh i suggest
so literally half the deaths of world
war ii for every um
a year that you know it gets delayed or
that number of lives saved for every
year that
gets brought earlier yeah one analogy i
heard that i liked was you know we're
all born time billionaires
with billions of seconds of life and
then we spend those and now you get
someone like warren buffett and i'm sure
he would trade
100 billion dollars for more billions of
seconds
uh but he can't right in fact healthcare
is the ultimate inelastic good
on your deathbed you'll spend any amount
of money to live even an hour longer
so certainly the economic incentives are
there the personal incentives are there
but because of
this concept that you know people who
don't know what they're doing are going
to hear
something and run out and like ingest
some substance and then die you know
drink bleach or
take too much rapamycin because of that
kind of fear we're not allowed to do any
real innovation or discovery and it's
literally killing us outright
and if we just reframed it as well no
it's not that we're dying of
aging we're dying because you won't let
us do the innovation do the research
it might take on a different take but i
was actually a little disappointed with
the coronavirus response because i
thought
we would have had faster trials of the
vaccines but the fact that they were
still kind of slow and even now the
deployment
is being held up because we have to
create these perfect vaccine delivery
packages
instead of just a kind of quick and
dirty vaccination and we have to go
through these very regimented protocols
rather than just saying everybody just
line up and let's just go as quickly as
possible
because we insist on doing things in
kind of this bureaucratic overly
controlled way we're still slowing
things down
and if coronavirus would get us to
accelerate our normal processes into a
wartime footing
then what will yeah i i also just want
to add that i think
given my experience with a highly
stigmatized
field of scientific research which is
psychedelics and psychedelic compounds
for intractable or difficult to treat
psychiatric conditions
i think that life extension or the
community itself and proponents thereof
could spend a lot of their oxygen and
calories trying to convince
regulators and three-letter acronyms to
classify aging as a disease and
therefore allocate
funding and i think that that is going
to be very difficult
and possibly wasteful compared to
decentralized or distributed funding
from
citizen philanthropists or donors of
various types i think
a lot of it's going to come down to to
independent financing
since that has been the case even all
the way up to phase 3 trials
for compounds that show tremendous
effect sizes
in the treatment of depression and ptsd
and so on
yeah i think another important thing
also is just kind of
international outreach and more
connections because ultimately
you know the us is not the center of the
universe um and
there's plenty of very smart people and
you know the eu
like singapore china india
canada whatever other places you know
there's a lot of
great talent there that i think could um
help
all of humanity solve these problems
faster
so if we can just work together on the
problem more
hopefully prevent stupid nationalism
from adding too much friction between
things
yeah i think a lot of the newer
generation rather than just being
patrons of the arts they're
trying to figure out how to become
patrons of science and instead of just
doing venture capital
we'd all like to figure out a model for
venture research because
we need more science right science is
upstream of technology and
the faster we can move science the more
it'll benefit us across the board
so i don't know where else you want to
take this tim but i have some kind of
more of the closing questions type for
vitalik if you're ready for those
i want to take this where you want to
take this novel okay
yeah so one question i kind of have is
given all the tumultuous change in 2020
because coronavirus was a trigger but it
was a trigger for accelerating a lot of
things that were already happening
like where do you think the world heads
in the next few years where
maybe your peers might disagree with you
what are your contrarian views or your
kind of
uniquely held individualistic views on
how things are going to play out that
are not yet consensus
and this is unfair because aging was a
good one you you made a solid
you went out on a limb on it example
that's like
the contrarian in the world but
definitely not contrarian among
kind of my circles i guess yeah when i
went through your writings i mean
the idea that there will be many
blockchains and many tokens right
is quite different the idea that yes the
internet has
increased the number of public goods
rather than the number of private goods
is actually quite contrarian because we
think of it as going more and more
private property but on the internet
it's one to many so
there's all these public goods and i
think you were the first one to really
hammer that point home in a big way and
then i think this aging thing is another
one so
i'm just digging seeing if there's any
more yeah no um another thing might like
uh that might have been um iconoclastic
two years ago but is
very much not today would be kind of
just geographic decentralization
even with the ethereum like we me we
took a very active effort of um
you know not making it too centralized
in any one country or any or any one
city in any one place
and i feel like we benefited a lot from
that but now of course um you know
everyone is uh
geographically decentralizing and
coinbase has announced that
like none of its uh managements that
live in san francisco and so forth
it's very hard to associate ethereum
with a single country i think it was
created by
mostly canadians and your blog has a dot
ca
top level well i'm canadian but then
right my blog has a dot ca the
foundation is
swiss and now there's um a yes
singaporean entity as well
a lot of the initial developers were
german um
you know a lot of uh developers are from
the us
as well um one of the most efficient
these two clients is
based in australia so i feel like we
kind of actually
like took the those values seriously and
then
and did it well and and ethereum has
spent you've
the foundation has spent a lot of time
in east asia i think i've seen you kind
of go from conference to conference in
east asia and korea and japan and
places like that spreading the word so
um it is quite
decentralized geographically what advice
do you have for someone who wants to get
into
ethereum and doesn't just want to go and
buy the token right who actually wants
to dive into the ecosystem
what what is the person to do to get
involved in the theorem community and
the ecosystem where
where are the points of leverage i think
just learning to build an application
and actually trying to build an
application
is i think one a great place to start if
that's the sort of thing that interests
you like even if you don't turn it uh
out as a full-time developer it's like
forcing yourself through the process
still helps you just
understand that you know what are the
different pieces and actually what
function do they serve
another example another approach
and there's well now obviously you get
kind of temporarily suspended but
generally
there's a lot of local communities that
you know kind of in-person meetups and
all that that people can be part of and
that's
often a great opportunity to uh gets to
meet other
ethereum people and there's a lot of
materials online
although generally i am a much more big
fan of uh hands-on learning
so kind of learning by doing instead of
learning by taking in information
um so you know highly recommend like
just trying to build one application
for uh a lot of people then
otherwise yeah there's just a lot of
different uh communities and like you do
have to just like
go in and start taking part in them yeah
for those of you who are curious i think
vitalik's blog
has spawned quite a few of the things in
the ethereum ecosystem like i think it
was one of your musings that led to the
creation of uniswap and
recently you've been talking about
rollups and social wallets and
uh and all kinds of other things that we
built on top although i
maybe this is the first year where i
feel like the community is outpacing
your ideas
with nifties and with some of the games
that are coming up on top of eth and so
on
it does seem like that there's a lot of
innovation going it's hard to keep up
it's very very hard to keep up that's a
good thing
for those of you also looking for what's
next down the rabbit hole
uh vitalik briefly mentioned zero
knowledge proofs i would say that you
know
the the beginning of the rabbit hole the
entrance is bitcoin
then you go a little further down you
find eth but then when you find zero
knowledge proofs that's the big
mind-blowing moment where you realize
just what crypto is capable of and there
are analogs for what crypto can do
that almost cannot be done in the real
world it's sort of like when you go into
physics and when you encounter quantum
mechanics
it sort of makes you rethink that no not
everything necessarily maps onto exactly
how i observe it
the same way when you get to zero
knowledge proofs you realize that the
levels of creativity and crypto that
enables are
greater than what we might have had
pre-crypto so that's also an interesting
space to kind of learn about and i think
zero knowledge proofs have
probably been incorporated into an
emerging ethereum system ecosystem even
more than we expected right because a
lot of people called it moon math early
on it was considered too hard to be
practical
but people have been chipping away at it
yeah that's that
the moon math is definitely
significantly less moony than it was
even one or two years ago like
even snarks another term for these as
your knowledge proofs some have just
become considerably simpler uh
sometime around one and a half years ago
i might even try to
make another post um one of my most
recent ones on nevitalik.cm where i
tried to talk about
like how roughly housing case snarks
work i actually feel like i made an
explanation that at least the high
school version of myself would have
understood which is like
it's still not perfect but it's like
significantly more
understandable than any of the previous
ones have been so i feel like the ideas
are definitely trickling down
oh so i i do have another answer to the
question of like what things are you
thinking about that other people are not
thinking about yet
um i think this is uh kind of taking
a kind of cultural and social context
seriously which sounds obvious but in
some ways it really isn't
right like even within the crypto space
i feel like a lot of people
in their models of uh you know is
bitcoin going to beat governments
um or are these things going to be
censorship resistance
they tend to look at it purely from a
yet technical point of view
and they basically are kind of
implicitly assuming that you know the
governments are going to try as hard as
they can um and uh
the crypto space is going to try as hard
as it can and it'll be a battle and
one side and you know that person's
preferred side is going to win but the
reality is that governments are not
trying as hard as they can
and a big part of the reason why is that
government
is not even so much an
entity as it is a battlefield right and
like what are the soldiers fighting on
the battlefield a lot of it is just the
cultural movements
and a lot of the success of
cryptocurrency
and blockchains i think they could
really have to do with the way that they
have
kind of interplayed with a lot of the
important cultural trends of the last 10
years like this
including things um like people's
distrust of financial institutions after
2008 i think people's distrust of
centralized tech companies
um after uh 2020 is also going to play a
big part
also just um another fascinating thing i
think
is like even like one thing that
surprised me is how cryptocurrency
managed to appeal to a lot of people who
would not normally think of themselves
as libertarians and that's something
that i think
like did end up even blindsiding a lot
of people
and the reason why that happened has to
do with kind of very
deep and specific aspects of like how
people think
i mean kind of how people think
ideologically right like a lot of people
think of like say authoritarians for
example as just people who hate freedom
and want to restrict things
but like the reality is there's lots of
people who are
like in favor of very specific
restrictions or even
in favor of restrictions that benefit
their own team but they're
just as easy very easily flipped to
being very pro-freedom when
you know it's their own team that's
being threatened or even when
you just kind of take things out of the
cultural context of uh
you know what should the government do
and into the cultural context of well
you know like how should technology work
so there's a lot of these kind of very
subtle effects um
that determine you know whether
blockchains and some of the ideals
behind blockchains that kind of succeed
and fail
and these are kind of very subtle
properties of like how humans think and
even
how humans interact with each other are
extremely important in a lot of ways and
the reason why they're
important is they just determine
the effectiveness with which people can
coordinate right like
you know humans are naturally kind of
very attuned to a kind of social trends
and humans have a lot of motivations
that have to do directly with um you
know what position they have within
uh kind of social trends and contexts
that are made up by other people
uh and this is just a space
that uh the you know watching in
cryptocurrency space is going to
navigate well um and
if it navigates it poorly then i think
blockchains will be stopped by
governments
or like they won't be stopped entirely
but you know the amount of usage can
easily be more than 90 percent lower
than
in otherwise would be but on the other
hand if blockchains can
you know successfully show to a kind of
large enough coalitions that this is a
valuable and this is a good thing for
the world
um then they can be very successful and
like this is just
something that you know the space needs
to have a better understanding of and
take seriously
yeah i think there's a lot of good
points he just made
what i like is that government is not an
entity or an enemy in the battlefield it
may just be the battlefield
that all of these factors can kind of
win simultaneously i think you made this
point in your blog
at in one place where you said that in
2020 you know big government won
big social media one big centralized
applications won but decentralized also
won
so there you can have multiple winners
these aren't necessarily either or
you've also made a an argument in one of
your
blog posts which is also beyond the
scope of this podcast but i think is
worth digging into for
people interested in game theory where
you basically point out that a lot of
the
toy models that we consider when we're
evaluating how these things will end up
have a so-called nash equilibrium they
have a solution in game theory because a
lot of individuals
are making decisions independently but
because majority coalitions rule
and people can collude or they can form
coalitions that you end up in these
unstable cycles
where you have a majority win one round
and then the definition of the majority
reshuffles and then they win the next
round
and so we see this in politics where it
seems like okay now the democrats are in
charge forever and oops no now the
republicans are in charge forever and
oops
no now the democrats are in charge
forever again and subtly underneath
what's going on is the definition of
democrat and republican is unstable
they're just coalitions that are being
formed and reformed as needed
so yeah these are lots of great
thought-provoking points i i'd really
love to
touch base with a vitalik who's 37 you
know ripe old age of 37 out of his
thousand-year
methuselah like lifespan
so naval i don't know if you have uh
questions remaining so i i really
just have one question and that is a pet
curiosity of mine it's related to
language learning
so you have studied quite a few
languages i looked at a clip
of you answering questions in a q a
at some point i don't know the year in
mandarin and
i was very impressed i went to two
universities in china
and nijang joang jang hawa so i wanted
to
ask if you could give advice
now having tested many things
used many approaches for someone who
wants to learn mandarin
what would your current recommendations
be to them
sure so for any language my usual
approach
is like i think at the beginning like
you do need some kind of
explicit program so like one thing that
i've used is the pims over podcasts
so that's p-i-m-s-l-e-u-r
so it's just a series of these 90
minutes oh sorry 90 30 minute podcasts
or 2700 minutes or about two days in
total
that you know you listen to one of them
every day and they just like
teach you the language from nothing up
to you know some
very basic level um over the course of
these 90 episodes so you start from that
but then even after that you don't have
nearly enough to understand anything um
so from there
sometimes you can find other um podcasts
like
and eventually you graduate to just like
regular podcasts in that language so
like things that are not even optimized
for language learning
well like at the beginning you do want
to find like resources that are
optimized for learning
flashcard apps i'm helped for chinese
specifically for
memorizing the characters or at least
you know the first they're kind of you
know
500 or a thousand or so there's plenty
of flashcard apps they're all about
equally good
and then once you kind of get past
some levels and you get to a level where
the best way to get even better is to
just talk to people another um kind of
path that works somewhat at the
beginning actually is like if you just
go into like you know a city and you
just like
start like reading various signs on the
street and you try your best to just
understand what you know
what they mean i mean if you uh see a
word that you don't understand you look
it up like that's um often useful
i also use duolingo as well that's
been helpful in some cases so just like
a combination of these
techniques and like you have to when you
start it's difficult and then when you
get past
some points like you get to a point
where you can just
kind of level up just from uh talking to
people from there
yeah great advice and i'll just add to
that that google translate
with image translation can be a
incredible savior in lands where you
don't understand the orthographies of
in japan my brother doesn't speak
japanese but we traveled there and he
was able to
more or less accurately translate kanji
the hans and the chinese characters
using
google translators it was remarkably
accurate it's improved a lot
and as i understand it you know another
thing that you've done
is is watching now i'd like to clarify
here is it watching films in other
languages or is it watching
english language films with subtitles in
your target language
which is also something i've done it is
watching films in other languages
sometimes we'll subtype those in english
got it thank you naval would you like to
to wrap up
no thank you thank you vitalik it's
really been an honor i think along with
uh you know nick sabo and hal finney and
wei dai and a few other
you know very influential people and
zuko and so on you've just been
incredibly influential in the
development of blockchains and
i believe that blockchains are the third
wave of the internet
after the web and mobile and they're
quite fundamental to how the internet
does and will operate in the future
you're probably the youngest one of that
group so uh you're
going to be involved in for hopefully a
very long time
uh and it's going to change uh the
computing as we know it
uh i'm betting on it i know many people
are and so thanks for your work and
thanks for taking the time to
help bring this to a broader audience
and i'm i think i'm not even the
youngest already
like hayden from uniswap is even younger
than i am and like you know the unislop
treasury has
more funds in it than neither in
valuation treasury so
this revolution proceeds fast man yeah
when i was first starting out my first
company i remember i was 25 and
ceo and company was valued highly in the
cto of the company he was in his mid 30s
he said huh
he said so you're used to being the
smartest young guy in the room right
just wait till you get old
and here we are thank you gentlemen
thank you hey guys this is tim again
just a few more things before you take
off
number one this is five bullet friday
do you want to get a short email from me
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every friday
that provides a little more soul of fun
before the weekend and
five bullet friday is a very short email
where i share the coolest things
i've found or that i've been pondering
over the week that could include
favorite new albums that i've discovered
it could include gizmos and gadgets and
all sorts of
weird that i've somehow dug up in
the
the world of the esoteric as i do it
could include
favorite articles that i've read and
that i've shared with
my close friends for instance and it's
very short it's just
a little tiny bite of goodness before
you head off
for the weekend so if you want to
receive that check it out
just go to four hourworkweek.com that's
4hourworkweek.com all spelled out and
just drop in
your email and you'll get the very next
one and if you sign up
i hope you enjoy it this episode is
brought to you by
peak p-i-q-u-e in their brand new
supplement
daily immune vitamin c optimized for
absorption
americans are arguably famous for having
the world's most expensive
urine so are you absorbing your vitamin
c or just peeing it out
studies have shown that you might absorb
less than fifty percent of vitamin c
when you consume amounts
over one thousand milligrams also a gram
those are the same thing peaks daily
immune is maximized for absorption with
liposomal encapsulation technology
liposomes help deliver vitamin c to
exactly where you need it your cells
not just your bladder and i've been
using their packets
now for a few weeks have gone through a
number of boxes
and i typically take one to two per day
as i would say maintenance kind of
support dose and i'll take
more than that if i feel any type of
cold coming on or any symptoms thereof
peak's unique formula supports a healthy
immune
system and daily immune features a
buffered non-acid
form of vitamin c that's gentle on your
stomach it is a powerful and
absorbable vitamin c that fits in your
pocket and tastes great so i will often
take a handful of these just stick them
in a jeans pocket for
the day and then every few hours open up
a packet plus it contains just seven
clean ingredients no preservatives fine
sugar or additives all you need to do is
open and squeeze it into your mouth
no glass water or spoon needed
personally i like to have a small chaser
of water or carbonated water but you
don't need it you can do it on the run
it's so easy and tastes so good think
black european elderberries
that is the flavor i've been consuming
you might choose to take it once or
twice a day or more as i do there's a
reason peaks products have more than
fifteen
thousand five star reviews people are
very happy with their products try it
for yourself risk-free with their 30-day
satisfaction guarantee
you either love it or you get your money
back so go to peakt.com
tim that's p-i-q-u-e-t-e-a dot com slash
tim
and use code tim tim check out to get
five percent off of your first order
plus
free shipping when you purchase a bundle
that's peak t
one more time p i q u e t e a
dot com slash tim and use code for five
percent off plus
free us shipping on a bundle
this episode is brought to you by
theragun i have
two theraguns and they are worth their
weight in gold i've been using them
every single day whether you're an elite
athlete or just a regular person trying
to get through your day
muscle pain and muscle tension are real
things that's why i use
the theragun i use it at night i use it
after workouts
it is a handheld percussive therapy
device that releases your deepest
muscle tension so for instance at night
i might use it on the bottom
of my feet it's helped with my plantar
fasciitis
i will have my girlfriend use it up and
down
the middle of my back and i'll use it on
her it's an easy way for us to actually
trade massages in effect and you can
think of it
in fact as massage reinvented on some
level helps with performance
helps with recovery helps with just
getting your back
to feel better before bed after you've
been sitting for way too many hours
i love this thing and the all new gen 4
theragun has
a proprietary brushless motor that is
surprisingly quiet
it's easy to use and about as quiet as
an electric toothbrush
it's pretty astonishing and you really
have to feel the theragun's
signature power amplitude and
effectiveness to believe it
it's one of my favorite gadgets in my
house at this point so
i encourage you to check it out try
theragun that's thera
t-h-e-r-a-g-u-n try theragon risk-free
for
30 days there's no substitute for the
gen 4 theragon
with an oled screen that's oled for
those wondering that's
organic light emitting diode screen
personalized theragon app an incredible
combination of quiet
and power so go to theragon.com tim
right now
and get your gen era gun today or you
can watch the videos
on the site which show you all sorts of
different ways to use it a lot of runner
friends of mine use them on their it
bands after long runs
there are a million ways to use it and
the gen 4 era guns start
at just dollars i said i have two i have
the prime
and i also have the pro which is like
the super cadillac version my girlfriend
loves these soft attachments
on that so check it out go to
theragun.com
tim one more time theragun.com
[Applause]
time